one of three questions on the ballot
would change your ballot forever
question three proposes ranked Choice
voting here in Nevada what is it
politics now hosts John langler explains
Simplicity versus engagement supporters
of question 3 think ranked Choice keeps
more voters involved in the political
process longer those who are already
part of the process Leia fought them
every step of the way it took a state
supreme court case in thousands of
signatures but November 8th ranked
Choice voting finally goes before Nevada
voters we want more people being engaged
Sandra Cosgrove is with better votes
Nevada one of the groups behind the
measure we spoke with her over the
summer so what we're saying is is we
think the political parties are
controlling the primary too much first
it creates an Open Primary meaning you
can vote for anyone on the ticket right
now you can only vote for Republicans if
you're Republican Or democrats if you're
a Democrat
the top five would then go on to the
general election in the general election
you would rank them one through five if
someone gets more than 50 percent in the
general election they win if no one gets
fifty percent it goes to an instant
runoff the candidate with the fewest
votes gets eliminated their second
choice gets their votes and that
continues until someone has 50 percent
question three would make it more
complicated
losing in time and time consuming to
cast a ballot in Nevada there is plenty
of opposition this rally was held on
Monday hosted by Progressive group
battleborn progress Republicans and
Democrats are against it we continue to
expand voter access we haven't had any
problems with our elections they've been
free and fair they call the system
puzzling the impact disenfranchising the
campaign funded by billionaires outside
Nevada this is a risky proposition that
will really be confusing to people and
it could cost thousands of ballots just
to be to be disqualified ranked Choice
voting is used in other places New York
City Alaska if approved it would take
effect next year
John langler 8 News Now